your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you where you are and
the fortunate thing going 2023 2024 is
you can change it the opportunities you
have right now at your age are so much
better than your parents at your age we
have the internet we have YouTube all
the best mentors and teachers are there
the information now is available the
opportunities are available the world
has changed and so if you don't like the
environment that you're in and the
people and the voices that are in your
head cool you can shift you can now
choose to be around more positivity and
and I encourage people to really do an
audit of the friends in your life the
people in your life and also who you're
following on Instagram on YouTube the
various platforms